міністри закордонних довідка рента
францією провернув оу вау до свого пузо
плану бога візитів до та у малюків у
україні червоними ми робимо жан-марк роли
типу до і внов думки через брин що
чином з франк-вальтер штайнмайєр розум
ви дошкуляти ce qui пресі
з авіаційних ситуація з турбували
чого хлопець від неї із ситуації турик
зірка красиво allow ви куна
неполітичних будинку план ост ще до змін
до конституції вибір закону
the web це не ios кутового рудого ми
просунулась вони далеко не достатньо
далеко мертвої на прийдуть не візу виду
міністри у прилюдно випили але заяву в не
україна порожня до тремтіння заповнена
потенціалу а влада така вчора бути
прогрес ути міністр за клікають
українських політиків низу зрозуміло якщо
напишеш ляху в пробувати венери форум і
головне у бідноти всі заряди тягу
правильний тон і чи оксидна так вже
складні негайно він біль ний курс на
модернізацію України
це питання таке на 2 чайні лики і
політичну воду ще всевид побачили не
політичні то граматики сил України
по ви не дієти спільна дасть руками
парламентські то президентські вибори та
як на парад одні вимагав і провиси ви
на Майдані
для заходу на шлях дуби рішення
українських проблем а че тильки
оголошеним фронту можна протестуючи то за
зовнішнім за вантажем у тих сажки всередину
вже не за вантажі олігархія чи то корупція так
сер в'януть і український політикум їжу
беруть у нього suspense тві в німецькій у
парламенті пил нас підстерігає потім
що ж буваєте в Україні тут працювати
Ще євроінтеграція може провалитися а
таз фіфа тариф або у когось було б
фатальної для україни я хочу провалитися
євроінтеграція а суть зв'язку з ланцюга
роду симпа означає вона для українців для
багатих цілих барнабас перспективніше
скла з України в Європу вам рпд шлях
їхніх біженців миття кінних про що дозволю
дочка неда
у карла гаргамель моно 1000 вас бувають
ціни не в Україні та практичного
катастрофа для демократії
за втечу то їй менше намагаються не
мати кайта французьких політиків до верби